[MUSIC PLAYING]
TREBOR SCHOLZ: So in
the next 40 minutes,
I'm going to tell you a little
bit about an emerging business
model that I've been working
on for the last three years
together with literally
hundreds of other people
around the world.
But before I go
there, I want to start
by sort of setting
up a bit of a context
for this work, which really
goes back to the last 40 years,
right?
So when we look at the
last 40 years there,
we've seen a steady
increase of the productivity
of the American worker,
which really rose by 73%,
while hourly pay stagnated
over the same time.
So it's around an increase
of 11% over the same time
which adjusted for inflation
really amounts to stagnation,
right?
And as you are well
aware, of course,
there is also a steep
increase in income inequality.
So 62 individuals owned the same
wealth as 3.5 billion people
in last year.
So I'm sure you were aware
of these kinds of statistics.
So you have an increase
in productivity,
a stagnation in wages.
And the project of
political democracy
has really propagated in the
last decades in many countries,
while workplace democracy has
really been left behind, right?
So there's a real
tension between the two.
You could also argue
that the web has really
hit rock bottom,
at least when you
look at the original
intentions of the founders
of the internet, and also Tim
Berners-Lee, who hadn't really
intended for this
kind of concentration
that we are seeing today.
And at the same time also,
over these last 40 years,
there's a much of a
real like nationalism
as we see it play
out right now very
clearly, in isolationism,
nationalism, and also
isolationism, right?
In the United States through
the next last election,
we saw also cultural
schisms really
playing out significantly.
But this is not
only happening here,
also, you know, France,
Germany, the Netherlands, so all
over Europe as well.
So again, over this
time period as well,
we had over these last
42 years a shift away
from direct employment.
So fewer and fewer people are
protected by the Fair Labor
Standards Act.
So by 2020, the projection
goes that 40% of Americans
will be freelance.
And so today already, you
have 55 million Americans
being freelancers,
so that there's
one in three Americans being
a freelancer already now,
which, you know, I'm not
exactly bemoaning employment,
per se, right?
I mean, OK, not that
everybody works for Google.
But you know, people in
other sets of employment
will not be as enthusiastic
about employment.
But there's one
thing that I would
insist is really a big loss,
which is rights, the worker
rights that came under the Fair
Labor Standard Act of 1938,
unemployment benefits, you
know, the eight hour work
day, workers comp,
all of which are
gone in this new setting
in this freelance economy.
And I think there's a broad
recognition that this really
is not sustainable.
Now, sort of switching to the
on-demand economy, sharing
economy, collaborative
economy, whatever
you want to call it
depending, you know,
if you're European
or American, you
could place the
beginning of that
maybe around 2005 with
Amazon Mechanical Turk,
2008 the financial
crisis on the heels
of which people were much more
likely to take low paying jobs.
And on the other
hand, and I think
there's I'm sure a broad
agreement of the people
in the room here, there's
a real significant consumer
convenience that comes with
this sharing economy, the likes
of Uber and Airbnb, right?
So there's a real
consumer convenience
that is appreciated.
There is access to work.
I mean, gigs, right?
Not employment, but gigs.
That has increased for people
who are in between jobs
and students, for example.
So I would very much
recommend my students
to work in that economy.
Because with TaskRabbit
or other companies,
the amount of money
you make are probably
more than they would
make otherwise.
So there are opportunities also
for the upper middle class.
So if you own a five bedroom
apartment on the Upper East
Side, it's like a really
fantastic opportunity
to rent that out when you spend
your weekends in the Hamptons,
right?
So you can make thousands
of dollars with that.
Of course, a bit different
if you live in a project
or are African-American.
As this Harvard
study showed, right--
a clear difference between
an African-American man
trying to rent out
and a white woman.
So there are all these sort
of racial aspects coming
into this economy as well.
And then this is
not necessarily.
I mean, people always say
like, well, you know--
I was just at a conference
and somebody says,
like, well, Uber and the
whole sharing economy,
how much of the GDP is that?
That doesn't really
matter to anyone.
It's like so, so small, right?
But what happens is with
many statistics, especially
government statistics,
they really
don't catch those people
working in that economy.
Because they only look
at employment or they
look only at the large amount
of income that people generate.
Only that is counted as a job.
And the rest falls to the
side and is not recorded.
But if you do look at
people working on platforms
and you do account also for
smaller amounts of income,
then like this Pew
survey here, you
will learn that
24% of Americans,
in fact, are or worked
on platforms in 2016.
So it's not a niche.
So I worked about this
for the last 10 years
and worked in digital
labor for a long time
on Amazon Mechanical Turk.
So the book that
you're seeing here
is sort of a mapping of
the digital labor landscape
and its many opportunities
and problems,
ending with a proposal of what
I call platform cooperativism.
And I congratulate Rachel that
she was able to pronounce that.
And then there's a
second book, which
we don't have here, which is
"Ours to Hack and to Own,"
which is really a collection
of some 40 authors responding
to this idea of
platform cooperativism.
And I will explain what
that is in a minute.
We also learned today that
Travis Kalanick stepped back
as CEO of Uber.
And this came on the
heels of, you know,
the Delete Uber campaign
if you remember this,
like when they joined the
economic board of the Trump
Administration.
200,000 people deleted
their accounts,
which shocked them
enough to withdraw
from this economic board.
And then, of course, the
very, very influential
and consequential blog post by
Susan Fowler, the former Uber
engineer, who revealed
the misogynistic work
culture at Uber.
And then there are other
movements and incidents
which would be demonstrated
by this #airbnbwhileblack
and others.
There were also demonstrations
of hundred thousands of drivers
in India, Uber and Ola drivers.
So there is a clear pushback
against this economy, right,
which you can see.
So I would suggest, and I'm
not alone with that opinion,
that we are really looking at
a market failure of the sharing
economy.
And that is based on
the privacy intrusions
that we saw with the likes
of these taxi of companies
that we discussed, but
also with the concentration
of data which is really
weakening competition, right?
And you see also technology
companies allowing
the exploitation of workers--
so that is also
well-documented and, by now,
quite uncontroversial--
and attacks on
public infrastructure
and many other reasons that
we can discuss as well.
And there's always
this discussion
in Silicon Valley of,
you know, framing all
of this as innovation, right?
And I think what we really
need is to really think
about whose problems
are actually solved
by this innovation, right?
Are these the problems
of middle class people?
Or are these real problems
of people in need?
But are these the
most burning problems
that this innovation solves?
Or whose problems are addressed?
So here you can see the
Barcelona City Council
in the background
in this photo that
really looks at
social value creation
and insists that basically
citizens and the needs
of citizens are
addressed through
technological developments that
are implemented in Barcelona.
So then there is the
obfuscation of language.
So you have this
wonderful mobilization
of the language of
love, of sharing,
all these like wonderful
sort of '70s discourses
that are mobilized to
sell commercial platforms.
And so, you know,
like Eva Illouz,
the Israeli sociologist, talks
about the language of intimacy
even being brought
into this discourse,
right, so that you
feel when you listen
to the discourses of
Airbnb or even Uber,
it sounds almost as if you
talk to a lover at night
on the pillow.
So it's this kind of
counterculture, obviously,
that is mobilized, right, the
language of counterculture.
So they really try
to sell themselves.
At the top of this
image, you can
see the sort of
counter-revolution,
counter-cultural forces,
where in fact, you know,
they're really not-- so
the California ideology.
And at the same time,
still sort of trying
to frame this sort of
40-year long development,
right, you also have a
technological displacement
of labor.
So with the development
really where you can already
foresee that a tiny group
of owners will be in charge
and will be the owners of
artificial intelligence,
how will this escalate
all of these developments?
So there is a lot of talk about
suddenly in Europe and now
also increasingly
in the United States
about universal
basic income, right,
and the post-work society.
Paul Mason wrote a book
about post-capitalism.
And you know, it's wonderful.
I would love to
live in a society
where my life opportunities
are dealing from wages.
That would be super awesome.
But this is also, certainly, in
this country a very long time
away, right?
It's very far off.
And I think what many of
these activist groups,
like Occupy Wall
Street in fact, were
lacking where they presented
critiques and perhaps even
a long-term vision.
But what they didn't offer
were near-term alternatives, so
things that you can do
when you leave this room
and you can do next
Thursday, right,
so direct projects
to engage with.
So my proposal is basically
with this platform cooperativism
is to work towards a diversified
digital economy in which you
don't have only four
or five players,
but also many small
businesses and one
that is not looking only for
solutions and technology.
So not having to solve
everything, click here,
philosophy or ideology, but
to really look broadly also
at the communities and what
they really need locally.
So platform cooperativism
is not a silver bullet.
It's not the solution
to everything.
But you can see it clearly in
tandem with other movements,
like the B-Corps
movement, credit unions,
the pro-commons movement,
the creative commons,
solitary economy,
community currencies,
and many other projects.
So it's really not a
multiculturalism, right?
So it's not about unicorns,
but really about zebras.
Because they, in fact, exist.
[LAUGHTER]
So it's also, you know, looking
at this historic moment,
there's a great opportunity
recognized by many people that
comes with the retirement
of the baby boomers, which
just means that a
lot of businesses
are changing hands, right?
So many of them are bought
by Goldman Sachs already.
But others are not, right?
And so here's an
opportunity to basically
rethink worker ownership and
to think about what it would
be like and also give workers
this awareness that they could,
in fact, be owning
the businesses
they are running also
in the digital economy.
I don't know if you're
familiar with these guys here,
the Rochdale Equitable
Pioneer's Society.
So this was the first
consumer cooperative
in Rochdale in England.
Interestingly, geographically
and also in terms of the time--
quite close to the
foundation of unions as well,
who came out of guilds
in the same region
around the same time.
So you had the first
cooperatives emerging really
as a response to a
precarity, right?
So they were starving.
So they said, well, let's
buy oatmeal, and milk,
and butter together, right?
And it will be cheaper.
And this became a
very successful model.
So if I would talk
with you individually,
you know, if you would
go to the cafeteria,
I'm sure like most
of you would tell me,
well, but cooperatives?
You know, come on.
We've seen this before
clearly not working, right?
It's an old-fashioned model.
And I've heard this
very many times.
But in fact, just
like this frog,
right, it's hiding
in plain sight.
Cooperatives are really
hiding in plain sight.
So from the Barcelona Futbal
Club to Ace Hardware, REI, s
Associated Press, these are
all cooperatives that are,
you know, enormously
financially viable.
And like you can see here, one
in three Americans, in fact,
is a co-op member.
I mean, I'm certainly
in many co-ops.
How many of you are co-op
members of some kind?
A-ha, so some of you, fantastic.
$500 billion in total
annual your revenue,
nearly 1 million jobs,
$5 billion in wages--
so it's definitely
not a failing model.
I mean, this is
something that's clear.
It's not taking over the
entire economy, clearly.
But it's also not going away.
And it's also not
a failing model.
I mean, I think this is quite
clear if you look at this.
Mondragon, the largest
worker cooperative
in the world in Spain,
has 74,000 members
and is a major economic
force in that country.
So what I'm proposing-- and I
have sort of worked my way up
to this, so now we
are sort of there--
is what I call-- and this
is hard to pronounce.
You can try this
three times fast--
platform cooperativism,
so the idea
to bring the
cooperative business
model to the digital economy.
In short, what would it
be like if the drivers
would own something like Uber?
What if residents would
own something like Airbnb?
And as it turns out, I wrote
a text about that in 2014
which kind of became viral.
And then I suddenly
realized like, oh my god,
what I was writing
about actually exists.
So there are many companies
like that out there.
So we created a large
conference in 2015.
Very many people attended that.
And out of it really became
an international movement
around this model.
So it's based on co-ownership
of the platforms,
so a co-operative ownership
of the platforms and the data,
and democratic governance.
So in the co-op tradition,
one worker, one vote, right,
this is how decisions
are made about what
happens on the platform.
And immediately, somebody
would say like, well,
how does this compare to Google?
Or how does this compare
to the unicorn model?
And well, there are, of course,
many disadvantages, but also
many advantages.
So advantages include that
they have larger resilience.
So there's research that shows
that cooperatives have a lower
failure rate after five years.
80% versus 41% of co-ops
will then still be around.
You know, it keeps
money in the community.
You have access
to member capital
when you're starting
as a startup.
There's ownership and
control of the people who are
involved in the cooperative.
This could be more
multi-stakeholder,
so in the sense of
users of a platform
owning the platform as
well, or really just
the people who are making a
living through that platform.
There are tax benefits.
There's a potential of a
cooperative data commons.
And I will talk about this
with an example afterwards.
And just sort of to
give you an idea,
many of these platform
co-ops take 5%
to operate the platform
compared to 25% to 50%
with the unicorn model, with
the investor-owned model.
so a clear difference.
Also, productivity benefits are
demonstrated with cooperatives.
So the transition, you know,
happens in various ways.
We see this, so
basically cooperatives
turning into platform
co-ops, unions joining co-ops
to form platform co-ops.
There are startups
that are transforming.
There are failed startups
that are turning over.
You know, like a Deliveroo-type
project in Belgium,
for example, turned
into a cooperative,
was just taken over
by the couriers when
the startup failed.
And then, of course, we see
mounting anti-trust efforts,
you know, against
many companies.
And the hope is that when
this happens, basically,
one of the split companies
could become a cooperatives.
So there are opportunities
to reinvent themselves,
but opportunities for
reinventions for co-ops,
for worker-owner, for
the worker ownership
model, for free
software developers,
and also for unions.
So the question
also becomes, how
can people make a decent living?
So everybody committed
to the commons,
how can they also make a living?
So there's a long tradition
and a strong movement
behind, you know,
Wikipedia and, of course,
open source, et cetera.
But what has often
been forgotten
is basically that
people also need
to be able to make a living.
And there are examples
of, for example,
free software cooperatives,
but there are very few.
So often, the assumption
is that these sort
of well-situated middle
class individuals who
contribute to the commons,
have the time to do so
and the resources.
And the question
becomes, now how can you
find business models that
contribute to the commons,
but also provide
people with a living?
OK.
So in which sectors
is this playing out?
It's all over the
landscape, right?
So it's vastly distributed.
It's not just one area.
It's everything from childcare
to software development.
There are cooperative
online marketplaces,
as you will see in a
second, health data
cooperatives, translation,
credit unions, crowdfunding,
journalism.
I will give you a few examples.
So on our site,
platform.coop, you
can see this sort
of, well, directory
where you can click in.
And you can actually see
the individual co-ops
and where they are located.
Yeah.
So I mean, afterwards, we
can go into more examples.
It's a patchwork of all these
different companies that
are in existence right now.
I just want to sort of
highlight a few, three or four--
Stocksy, for example.
So it's a really fascinating
and really wonderful
company started by the founders
of iPhoto who basically
were then bought
out by Getty Images
and started their own stock
photography site in Canada
based on the idea,
basically, of pushing back
against the sort of very cliched
stock photography, right?
The white man in the suits
in these sort of boardrooms,
you know, that's really not what
work looks like for most people
anymore, right?
So they wanted to
create a different kind
of stock photography.
But they also
wanted to make sure
that the photographers that
are contributing to the site
can make a living, right?
So it's not about the
race to the bottom,
but it's actually
about commitment
to a smaller group
of photographers.
So they made $10.7 million last
year, $300,000 in dividends
and supported 960 photographers.
So 960 photographers
contributed to this cooperative
in 63 countries.
And they served 124 of
the Fortune 500 companies.
And so it's a great product.
But at the same
time, it's operated
in a way that is very
different to invest
their own companies in that they
really invest in the workers,
if you like, in
the photographers.
Because they say, here
are our 960 photographers
that we commit to.
And so we need to make sure that
they deliver the product that
makes us successful.
So that gives them the drive
to actually educate them.
So they have these online
meetings, a continuing
education if you like, for
the online labor market
where they show them
what kind of product
they are looking for, so that
they can improve and deliver
more photography that
they can accept, right?
So this is one example.
Here they are.
Now, about a month
ago in May, Up & Go
was founded here in New
York, which is basically
a platform for home
cleaning, so you should all
use it, which basically
connects people to cooperatives
in their neighborhoods.
So you order a cleaning
service through this platform
and will always be connected to
a co-op in your neighborhood.
And the difference is that
they basically charge 5%.
So 95% of the profits go to
these low-income immigrant
women.
And they're interesting.
I mean, we could talk
about this for hours.
But there are interesting
design differences
as well where, for example,
there are no individual worker
profit.
And there's also no
reputation system.
So what you will
find on the site when
you type in your
zip code, all you
get is a photo of
the cooperative.
And somebody from this
co-op will service you,
but you do not know who.
And this was a long
discussion with those workers,
for example.
And we can talk about that.
It's an interesting difference.
So this is what it looks
like, very simple interface.
And here is one of cooperatives
that services the site.
So if you want to do something
for low-income immigrants,
use this site.
This is then what you
get in the interface
when you decide
whom to work with.
OK.
And I'm going to go fairly
fast through a few more.
Loconomics is a labor market
for freelance in San Francisco.
SO anybody from
psychotherapists,
to massage therapists,
tutors, and so on,
go through the site
to find clients.
It's a labor brokerage and
run as a cooperative, right?
And interestingly, again,
like different to the venture
capital model, their
bylaws protect exit, right?
So a pivot a impossible, right?
So nobody could buy them out.
They will always
be a co-op-owned.
So Green Taxi in Denver has
800 members, Denver, Colorado,
from 37 countries.
Each of them contributed
$2,000 to, you know,
basically start
launch the upstart.
And they were helped by the
communication local 7777
to basically deal
with local regulation
to sway that in favor
of the cooperative,
just like Uber has to
buy their regulation.
Also, of course, cooperatives
have to do similar things.
They captured one third of
the Denver market, right?
So this is this model pronounced
Midata in Switzerland coming
out of ETH in Zurich that
basically looks at the fact
that there are so many
healths data that we have
today from 23andMe to Fitbits.
And nobody really has
in central control.
So there is no central ownership
of those data, partially
for, you know,
regulatory reasons.
The government doesn't
allow Google, for example,
to do that.
There are many laws against it.
But with cooperatives,
it could be different
where you basically say
that there are national data
co-ops for patients
that can then
decide to release these data
to their general practitioner
to researchers or even
sell them to the industry.
And the profits would never
go to the individuals,
but go into public research
or civic-minded projects.
This is how the
project is set up.
It's already profitable
in Switzerland.
It's now also starting
in Spain and in Germany.
So this is the current model, so
a corporate central ownership.
And their model is basically
a federated cooperative model,
where because the laws
about healths data
are so different from
country to country,
you could basically release
your data across borders
through the sort of federated
cooperative data commons.
There is more conceptual
work underway with Fairbnb,
where basically groups in--
actually, now there
are two groups
with the same title, confusingly
enough, Fairbnb in Canada
and FairBnB in Amsterdam.
And the Canadian model is
really about changing regulation
in terms of Airbnb.
The Dutch model is
really about building
a platform that will
be resident owned
and a cooperative ownership
that allows residents to say--
and I don't know if
you're familiar with this.
But you know, cities like
Barcelona and Amsterdam
are flooded with
tourists, which creates
very serious problems, really
way too many tourists, right?
So your local grocery suddenly
turns into a Nutella store
which locals don't
really want, right?
Or in Barcelona-- nothing
against Nutella, right?
Or in Barcelona you have,
like, a vegetable market
that is flooded with
tourists who don't really
buy vegetables.
And the locals don't
want to go there anymore,
because they can't
really shop there,
because there are so
many tourists-- so
like issues like that and
partly caused by Airbnb.
And so basically
the idea in part
is also to put a limit
on how many people
can be in the city at one time.
And that would be controlled
by citizens or in collaboration
with the city.
And so it's an
interesting project.
Then I don't know,
some of you may
have heard about that
my colleague Nathan
Schneider and the campaign
associated with that, tried
to come up with the $12
billion that it would take
to buy to Twitter,
which is up for sale
and turn it into a cooperative.
And first, I thought, well,
this will never go anywhere.
Hundreds of articles
around the world written
about this and the
shareholders voted on it
with 4% of shareholders
in favor of discussing it.
It will be discussed again
at the next board meeting
next year, so a democratic
ownership of the internet also
being part of this discussion.
So there are
journalism platforms,
like Positive News in the UK
that are cooperatively run.
In the United States, you may
be familiar with Banyan news,
which really tries
to think about how
to push back against fake news.
through cooperative
ownership and Resonate,
which just launched
after a very long time
basically in Berlin which is
a cooperatively owned music
streaming service trying to
create competition for Spotify.
And if you look at the numbers,
it's quite interesting.
So basically, it pays
musicians 200% more
on 100,000 plays than Spotify.
It basically uses blockchain
to make a living for musicians
again.
And it's a stream to own model.
So the more often
you're streaming a song,
the more you own it.
So you basically put--
link it to your credit card.
And with every play, it
deducts a few cents until you
own this song in total.
And the platform
itself is owned,
as you can see at
the bottom here,
by artists, so the musicians
themselves, the listeners, so
a multi-stakeholder
model, and also
the employees of
the company, right?
So it's a mixed model like this.
There are sanctuary
platforms that create--
like in Germany with its 1.5
million refugees, many of them
are actually IT professionals.
And now they are in
some refugee camp.
I don't want to call it camp.
And they, you know, can't
work, because they can't leave.
But if they would be
able through a platform
like that be able to
connect to Germans
who are looking
for IT work, this
would create basically
a market like that.
Lastly, Fairmondo, an
online labor market
that overtly tries to
compete with eBay and Amazon,
so it's focused on fair
products or fairness
in all regards really, so fair
labor, selling the fair phone,
and other fairly produce
products, et cetera.
So they're really
into transparency,
as you can see here.
So, yeah, of course,
I should end this talk
by saying that there are,
of course, also quite
enormous challenges which have
of course to do with funding,
unsurprisingly, and then issues
like the value proposition.
So with something
like Stocksy, you
could see that they came
out of the corporate sector.
And they really
understand what it
means to create a good product
that functions in the market.
Other companies are really
so excited about starting
a cooperative that
they are not so focused
on the value proposition, and
then have problems with that.
There's a question of education.
I mean, I don't know if any
of you went to business school
here.
Anybody got an MBA?
I mean, they're not even taught
about the co-op model, right?
Certainly, in
universities they're
not taught about
it anymore either.
And so people just
really don't know, right?
And yet, like I said,
hidden in plain sight,
they are really all around
us, one in three Americans
being part of one.
So it's definitely a model
that's all pervasive,
and yet sort of overlooked.
And there's this problem
of decentralization.
Of course, the network effect--
I don't have to tell you that--
plays out in favor of
the existing platforms,
scaling issues, et cetera.
But you know, so the question
then comes basically,
how can you create institutions
that support this new economy?
And so we started with
a platform.coop, which
is basically a hub where
people who want to start co-ops
like that from
all over the world
can have a starting point
where we are working
and hope to perhaps
interest you as well
to work with us on designing
an open source platform that
could be used around the globe.
Because what
happens right now is
that people basically from
San Francisco to New York
to Argentina to India are all
starting the same project.
They're all designing
these labor platforms.
And of course, it's a huge waste
of effort and money, resources.
So there could be an
open source kernel
that could be then
plucked and, with the help
of local programmers,
adapted to their local needs.
We have an overview you
can see on the website
where you can sort
of follow up on that
and get involved if you like.
We set up a consortium, which
basically brought together
institutions that
are in support.
So, you know, like
from the Berkman Center
to MIT and to Oxford Institute
for Internet and Society,
and then many cooperatives and
businesses as well and as well
as unions who are basically
all working to support this.
And you can join
us on November 10
to 11 at the New
School here in New York
just a few blocks from here when
we have our next big gathering.
We hope to get Bernie
Sanders to come--
and the people's
disruption platform
co-ops for global challenges.
And this is where
I will leave it.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Any ideas on how
big companies like Google
could turn into a
co-op, number one,
if you thought about the
challenges of something
like that?
And number two,
in a co-op world,
how do you prevent the
capitalist, the VC basically,
from eating co-ops?
Not because they're
going to acquire them,
but because they're
going to starve them
by doing aggressive price
cutting and these kind
of the things.
TREBOR SCHOLZ:
Well, I mean, there
is increasing turn of anti-trust
measures against Google,
people writing books about
it and policy makers getting
more interested in the idea.
So if this will ever happen
is the other question.
But if there is such a break
up, like I said in my talk,
the idea would be that one
of these smaller companies
could be run as a cooperative
or could be mandated
to be run as a cooperative.
And to answer your
second question,
they don't take VC money.
So the money comes from users.
So for example,
Fairmondo put a cap
on 20,000 euros per investor.
And they are users of the site.
So they are members
of the co-op.
So they get their capital
from members, not from VC.
So there is no
controlling influence.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, let me
clarify the second question.
What I meant is how do
prevent a company like Uber
to compete with the
Green Taxi of Denver?
TREBOR SCHOLZ: Oh, [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Because
Uber could say,
hey, free rides for everybody
for the next five years,
because it's powered
by VC capital.
And then Green Taxi
dies, and Uber lives.
How do you prevent that?
TREBOR SCHOLZ: Yeah, right.
Well, you can't
prevent that, but you
can look at markets
and industries
in which this model could be
more successful than in others.
For example, in the United
States as much as in Europe,
home health care is a huge issue
where this model could really
succeed very well.
But you see it also in Denver.
There are cities,
like Austin, right?
In Austin, there are several.
There are platform
co-ops and also a DAO,
if you're following that
discussion, basically
that work in markets where
Uber is not so dominant
or left in fact.
For example, Italy.
So the Italian government
just informed us
that they are basically
financing a study
to see if platinum co-ops could
be rolled out all over Italy.
Because Uber announced that
they will leave the country.
So you know, I guess
like one answer
to that would be in niches
where they are not competing
or in niches where
they don't operate.
It's, of course, I
would think this.
The idea here is not
to destroy Uber, right?
I hope I made that clear.
But the objective is a more
diversified digital economy
and one where ethical
alternatives like that
have some room in
the market, right?
I think it would be
unrealistic to think that they
would dominate those markets.
AUDIENCE: Does
anyone here use Juno?
I use Juno.
TREBOR SCHOLZ: I mean,
Juno was interesting,
because it had a
worker-ownership model.
I don't know if
you followed this.
So they basically
said if drivers
have a high performance, they
will own part of the company.
Only problem is that they
then were purchased by Gett
and betrayed the workers.
And this is not really
happening anymore.
So we deleted them
from our website.
But you know, there
are dozens of companies
that do operate, like
Cotabo in Italy, ETX.
I mean, there are
many examples--
Austin Rides.
AUDIENCE: The thing that
stuck out to me about this--
because I think it's easy to
argue that over time overall,
it's cheaper for everyone.
But there's a minimum
buy in for people
who want to be part
of these co-ops.
And I'm wondering how
that affects something
you talked about earlier, which
is whose problems are getting
solved by these things.
You mentioned Up & Go.
I don't know if
that's an example.
TREBOR SCHOLZ: Well,
you know, there
are lots of different
ways of funding these.
So like Up & Go was funded
through foundation and a bank,
right?
So Barclays Bank
and the Robin Hood
Foundation here in New York.
[INAUDIBLE] a
foundation that aims
at alleviating poverty in New
York City invested in that.
And then there are, you
know, blockchain schemes
where people basically tried
to find new funding ways.
We are just about to create a
plot from co-op crypto token
to basically allow people
in the crypto token system
to invest in this model as well.
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't that lead
to situations like Juno,
though, if you're
getting external funding,
but you want people to
be owning the company?
TREBOR SCHOLZ: Not really.
AUDIENCE: OK.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I was wondering
if you could talk about kind
of where a co-op might not
be the best thing where kind
of a larger company where you--
TREBOR SCHOLZ: Right, yeah.
AUDIENCE: I mean, when I think
about Uber, the thing that's
nice about it is I can go
almost anywhere and use it.
Whereas, these co-ops, you
seem to be kind of focused
in smaller areas rather than
kind of a large extended co-op.
TREBOR SCHOLZ: Well,
it depends, right?
So yeah, I agree with you.
So the most sensible
areas would be
I think where research
and development is not
very extensive.
So probably not in
automated cars, right?
Probably not in
self-driving cars.
So you know, I mean,
development of AI i
would not place on small
cooperatives, right?
But even in that discussion, it
would be interesting to see--
and there are
already cooperatives
that actually contribute to
the research of AI companies.
They are not doing
it themselves,
but they are part
of this picture.
They're trying to insert
themselves in there.
That was your first question.
But then you had the second one?
AUDIENCE: Oh, no.
That was kind of my--
TREBOR SCHOLZ: Yeah, yeah.
No, I completely agree with you.
And this is why areas, for
example, like, you know,
home health care,
like I say it again.
You know, we saw it being very
successful in the Netherlands,
you know, where basically groups
of nurses form cooperatives,
create websites with services
like prenatal care for Latino
women.
You know, there's
this [INAUDIBLE],,
for example, done here
in Southern California
where these nurses traditionally
through temp agencies
would pay 50% to
the temp agency.
And now they have a
very different situation
when they run their own
operation like that.
So there are clear advantages
for particular groups I think.
So, yeah.
AUDIENCE: One other
different question.
You kind of mentioned that
there would be this ideal co-op
platform kernel.
TREBOR SCHOLZ: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: And we make platforms
here a little bit sometimes.
TREBOR SCHOLZ: I've
heard about that.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
What kind of main
features do you
think would exist in
this type of platform?
TREBOR SCHOLZ: Absolutely.
Well, it's really
for apps, right?
Well, it's one worker
facing, one client facing,
for iOS and for Android.
So it's really like four apps
that you would have to demo
and have to develop.
And then they would have to
plug into different applications
locally, right?
So it would just be the
kernel, and then local.
So you know, it would
be somebody [INAUDIBLE]
what you would
consider small grant,
I would consider an
enormous grant for this.
And so we tried to
make a dent in that
and actually hope to have this
done in the next two years.
So I mean, if any of you
are interested in this
and think that they would
like to support this,
we would, of course,
highly welcome that.
AUDIENCE: I had a question
about policy changes--
TREBOR SCHOLZ: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --that could
encourage more co-ops or level
the playing field or take
a holistic approach to--
TREBOR SCHOLZ: Absolutely.
AUDIENCE: --creating, you know,
a world that results in more
co-ops or whatever
that would be--
TREBOR SCHOLZ: No, absolute.
AUDIENCE: --if people
are thinking about that
or if you have anything
to say about that.
TREBOR SCHOLZ: Yeah.
No, so part of what this
organization, the PCC,
the Platform Cooperatives
and Consortium does
is we write policy
briefs for senators.
And I don't know, in October,
we talked to the G7 about this.
And you know, we wrote
one for Kirsten Gillibrand
who requested one.
Because Kirsten Gillibrand
and Bernie Sanders
created this package on May 11,
I think, they released that,
where they proposed a large
push for cooperatives.
And so I think the
interventions are mostly
on the municipal level, right?
I wouldn't have all too much
hope on the federal level
at least for the next
four years, and so there.
But I think you can work with
cities very much so hoping
to bring about local legislation
that is in favor of that.
And there's a
whole sort of list.
I mean, I have in
fact even a slide--
I can show it to
you afterwards--
which lists the things
that we're proposing,
like a revolving loan fund for
platforms co-ops town hall.
Set up townhalls to
discuss these issues
and many other things.
The problem with
American policy is
that it's relatively
friendly to monopolies,
but it's really
hostile to cartels.
And something like
Mondragon, which is really
a network of cooperatives, would
definitely be seen as a cartel
and would not be tolerated.
So you have to find
ways to influence that,
as the people in Denver did.
Thank you, everybody.
[APPLAUSE]